- La vice-première ministre
du Canada traquée et intimidée
lors de son passage en Alberta
vendredi dernier
L'incident a été déno
de toutes parts.
- C'est une menace
à notre démocratie.
- Le débat sur la sécurité des
ministres fédéra r r r relancé.
Après la dernière élection,
le ministre de la sécurité
publique avait déjà reçu
le mandat d'améliorer
la protectioélélélélus.
Selon nos informations,
l'incident impliquant Chrystia
Freeland a eu l'effet d'un
électrochoc à Ottawa et l'enjeu
est mantntntnt considéré
comme plus urgent.
MARCO MENDICINO, ministre
fédéral de la Sécurité publique
- Toutes les options restent
lalalala table. On travaille
avec la GRC, avec le sergent
sur la colline, avec toutes
les forces policières.
- Des propositions devraient
être soumises au Conseil
des ministres au cours
des prochaines semaines.
Parmi les scénarios à l'étude :
im'A'A'A'Assemblée nationale
du Québec, où chaque ministre
a droit à un garde du corps.
Le coût ne devrait pas être o oé
de l'opposition officielle.
GÉRARD DELTELL, député, PCC
Louis-Saint-Laurent, Qc- On estd
même. C'est sérieux, le Canada,
là. Pourquoi doit-on faire
des économies de bout
de chandelles comme ça?
- Un service de sécurité
amélioré devrait être disponible
pour tous les élus qui en font
la demande, y compris les chefs
de parti, selon Yves-François
Blanchet.
YVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET
chef, Bloc québécois
- Je crois qu'il ne faut pas
en effet, attendre qu'il y ait
quelque chose qui se produis
(brouhaha)
- Ces derniers mois,
les actes d'intimidation
se sont multipliés envers
les politiciens.
Comme ces manifestants
agressifs, qui ont pris à partie
le chef du NPD le printemps
dernier en Ontario.
(manifestation)
Où ces cailloux lancés
au premier ministre lors de la
dernière campagne électorale.
La pandémie et les restrictions
sanitaires ont exacerbé
les tensions.
La menace envers les
politiciens a changé, affirme
cet ancien garde du corps
de Stephen Harper.
MICHEL ANTAYA, ancien garde
du corps Steararararper
- Les groupes n'étaient
pas aussi radicalisés puis
que la menace était contrôlée.
- La simple présence d'un garde
du corps pourrait changer
la dcrcrcrcroit-il.
- Juste le fait d'avoir une
présence quelconque, la personne
qui est mal intentionnée va y
penser à deux fois avant d'agire
de la protection à la pièce aux
élus victimes de menaces jugées
sérieuses. Des boutons d'alarme
ont aussi été offerts
aux députés en cas d'urgence.
Si des mesures supplémentaires
s'ajoutent, certaines pourraient
rester secrètes,
pour des raisons de sécurité.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-Canada, Ottaw